this is you it's Friday and you've just
finished your first week of classes
you're an ambitious guy so you've
already tackled the reading for Monday
and Tuesday and Wednesday at this rate
by the end of the weekend you'll have no
homework left for the whole month of
September but truth is all these new
people and ideas are making you wonder
if you'll get burnt out so you decide to
take a break you could a hide in your
room playing video games for hours on
end and when a guy on your hall asks why
don't get a concert on the clock you say
no good be double down on studying until
the librarians kick you out hello or see
when your friend adds I want to get a
concert in the quad you say sure
[Music]
this is Ashlyn and this is Alice
together they run the Student Activities
Board the group on campus that gives you
opportunities to step away from homework
meet new people and more and it's not
just concert on the quad they host the
source mock rock garden party caller
runs Fall Fest trivia time of regalia
Thank You red world only nice gate I eat
trick hooking presents positron Haleh
Palooza and that's just the big stuff
when they're not hosting events you can
find them in the SAT on this right there
in the Student Union so you go to
concert on the quad you hear a few bands
and you have a great time the next
morning you're relaxed you've made
memories and you're ready to tackle the
next reading just maybe take one
assignment